Hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu Forschergeist, dem Podcast des Stifterverbandes für die deutsche Wissenschaft. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle hier zur 39. Ausgabe unserer Gesprächsserie über Wissenschaft, über wissenschaftliche Arbeit, wissenschaftliche Fragen und vielleicht auch die Aufgaben der Wissenschaft. Und heute wollen wir mal ein wenig in eine Zukunft blicken, die vielleicht sogar schon die Gegenwart ist. Und schauen aber auch gleichzeitig weit zurück in die Geschichte der Erde dabei. Denn wir blicken vielleicht auf ein neues Zeitalter, was schon angekommen ist oder vielleicht gerade entsteht. Und um darüber zu sprechen, begrüße ich heute Reinhold Leinfelder. Schönen guten Tag.
Guten Tag.
Herr Leinfelder, Sie sind Wissenschaftler. Richtiger Wissenschaftler. Es gibt so manchmal Gäste, die ihre eigene Rolle als Wissenschaftler ein bisschen in Frage stellen. Auch wenn ich eigentlich einen recht breiten Begriff selber pflege. Jeder, der in gewisser Hinsicht Wissen schafft ist irgendwo auch Wissenschaftler. Warum wollten Sie das werden und wie sind Sie das geworden?
Ja das überlege ich mir selbst auch oft. Ich hatte nach dem Abitur durchaus Entscheidungsschwierigkeiten. Ich habe mich sehr für Natur interessiert. Ich hatte Frösche gefangen und Eidechsen und habe die gut gehalten. Habe mich schrecklich aufgeregt, dass die aufgrund von Bauten, zum Beispiel eines großen Golfplatzes plötzlich in meiner Ecke, wo ich sie immer gesehen habe, verschwunden sind, weil die Tümpel überdüngt wurden. Also das hat mich sehr beschäftigt und da wollte ich auch irgendwie mich einbringen.
In welcher Region war das?
Das war in Augsburg. Bei Augsburg in den westlichen Wäldern. Und ich war aber genauso an Sozialem interessiert. Habe mir also auch überlegt, soll ich vielleicht Psychologie oder Sozialwissenschaften studieren und dann war ich noch Musiker, Schlagzeuger. Und in einer Band, in einer Jazzband, das hat viel Spaß gemacht. Also das Kulturelle, ich habe sogar mal ein bisschen Laienschauspiel und so etwas gemacht, hat mich auch interessiert. Aber dann ging ich in Richtung Naturwissenschaften. In der Biologie, hat man mir in der Studienberatung gesagt, ja und wir machen da ganz tolle Sachen, wir schneiden zum Beispiel Frösche auf. Das wollte ich überhaupt nicht.
Die armen Frösche jetzt auch noch aufschneiden.
Dann dachte ich, ich könnte ja den Regenwald retten und bin in die Forstwissenschaften in die Studienberatung. Da hat man mir dann viel erzählt von Klafter Holz und Ökonomie und was ich für eine tolle Karriere als bayrischer Staatsbeamter hier machen könnte. Das war mir damals auch nicht so ganz das was ich angestrebt hatte. Und irgendwie bin ich aber über diese Diskussion auf die Geologie gekommen. Und habe da mal ein schlaues Buch gelesen dann noch und dachte, ja da kommt du auf der Welt rum. Da hast du ganz viel verschiedene Nebenfächer, das könnte etwas sein. Und das habe ich probiert und habe es nie bereut.
Aber Sie haben tatsächlich den Weg über die Studienberatung gesucht? Also das war gar nicht so, dass so die Geologie von Vornherein irgendwo so im Innersten schon loderte?
Die war in der Schule nicht groß angeschrieben. Da hatten wir etwas Sozialgeografie gemacht. Da hatte ich eine gute Note. Also dachte ich schon, vielleicht bist du da irgendwie geeignet. Aber ja ich habe mich da breit informiert. Ich war da wirklich, will nicht sagen, verunsichert, sondern ich war eigentlich offen für alles und das war vielleicht fürs Studium auch wichtig. Das sage ich auch Studierenden oft. Mit mir haben doch viele angefangen, die wollten immer schon Paläontologe werden. Die haben immer schon Fossilien gesammelt. Und die waren zum Teil so frustriert im Grundstudium, weil da man Physik, Chemie, Mathematik gemacht hat, dass die das reihenweise aufgegeben haben und ich war eben breit vorinteressiert und fand das eigentlich alles irgendwie spannend. Und dann wurde es ja richtig geologisch und paläontologisch, zu etwas späterer Zeit im Studium.
Das ist ja so eine Eigenschaft der Geologie, dass es wirklich eine sehr breit gestreute, sehr hoch andere Disziplinen kombinierende Wissenschaft ist. Kurze Nachfrage zu dieser Studienberatung, das interessiert mich jetzt gerade. Das war die Studienberatung einer Universität oder davon entkoppelt?
Das war in der Universität. Ich muss da einen unserer Lehrer am Gymnasium loben, der schon im Vorfeld mal mit uns von Augsburg nach München gefahren ist und wir uns einen Tag lang mal in alle möglichen Vorlesungen einfach reingesetzt hatten. Das fand ich schon eine gute Sache, um da auch mal in andere Sachen reinzuschnuppern. Also das war sehr schön. Also der andere Treiber, den ich da vielleicht noch hatte neben dieser noch ein bisschen mehr fachspezifischen Frage, was machst du denn? Für mich war schon wichtig, es musste mich faszinieren können. Es musste sich auch ein bisschen neu anfühlen und ich wollte halt diese Zusammenhänge eigentlich auch immer sehen. Und was dann aber auch schnell dazu kam während des Studiums, also als ich da zum Beispiel in meiner Diplomarbeit über Mikroorganismen, die 150 Millionen Jahre alt sind, gebrütet habe, dachte ich mir immer, hilft es der Gesellschaft irgendetwas? Also ich musste mich selbst vor mir rechtfertigen und auch nach außen.
Und ich glaube das ist so diese Antrieb, wieso ich doch auch sehr in der Wissenschaftskommunikation drin bin oder das immer als integrativen Bestandteil der Wissenschaften, die ich mache, gesehen habe.
Also am Ende wurde es die Geologie und die Paläontologie und die Geobiologie.
Geobiologie als, wenn man so viel, Aktuopaläontologie, so hat man früher teilweise gesagt. Also wenn man Aktuopaläontologie, wenn man sich heute die heutigen Vorgänge als Modell ansieht, um früheres zu verstehen. Ganz konkret habe ich dann viel über fossile Korallenriffe gearbeitet und da ist eben Biologie genauso wichtig wie Geologie. Und eben auch komplexe Zusammenhänge. Und wir haben dann, eben nicht so, wie das viele andere machen, angefangen mit heutigen Korallenriffen, um ein Modell zu haben, wie es vielleicht früher war, sondern haben es eher umgekehrt gemacht. Wir haben versucht, die Evolution der Korallenriffe durch die Zeit besser zu verstehen und das heute als Produkt dieser geologischen und biologischen Evolution zu sehen. Und das kann zusätzliche Erkenntnisse wirklich bringen. Das ist so ein geobiologischer Ansatz.
Ja also man blickt sozusagen auf existierendes, aber man liest quasi die vollständige Erdgeschichte, nicht die vollständige, aber einen großen Teil, daraus heraus?
Man sieht an diesem Beispiel, um das mal kurz zu erläutern, dass sich eben Korallenriffe, obwohl es die schon sehr sehr lang gibt, knapp 400 Millionen Jahre, wo es mit den ersten Vorläufern losgegangen ist, dass sich die halt immer mehr eingenischt haben, dass es da auch große Umbrüche gab und dass diese heutige Einnischung, die wir haben, angepasst, also bei tropischen Korallen, an extremen Nährstoffmangel, an Flachwasser, an Licht, dass das nicht immer so war. Und es ist ebne auch spannend zu sehen, gibt es da vielleicht noch Relikte, Atavismen, gibt es heute noch Korallen, einfach flexibler sind? Daran forschen wir auch heute noch hier. Auch eben eine wichtige Sache, die Resilienz, die Elastizität von Korallen so zu verstehen, ob da noch so Relikte aus der Erdgeschichte irgendwo übrig geblieben sind, die jetzt vielleicht wieder zum Tragen kommen in Zeiten des ganz raschen Klimawandels, Meeresversauerung etc.
Heute sind Sie Professor an der FU Berlin. Wie kam es dazu?
Also ich war an verschiedensten Universität Professor für Geologie und Paläontologie oder historische Geologie und Stratigraphie auch. Also mich hat es eigentlich immer so ein bisschen rumgetrieben. Ich habe in Stuttgart angefangen und habe da versucht, dieses Institut zu modernisieren und weiter auszubauen. Und übrigens damals, 1989 habe ich da angefangen, ich glaube ich war einer der ersten, die auch Webseiten gemacht haben für geowissenschaftliche Institute und Zusatzinformationen, Jurassic Reef Park und so etwas ist aus dieser Zeit immer noch irgendwo im Netz vorhanden. Damals sogar von Science besprochen worden, was mich sehr gefreut hat. Und dann bin ich nach München gegangen, auch weil es da eine neue Herausforderung mit gab, weil ich dort für die naturwissenschaftlichen Sammlungen des Freistaats Bayern mit zuständig war.
Und auch da das Kommunikative, aber auch das Kulturelle quasi dann mit integrieren konnte. Und dann bin ich eben nach einer gewissen Zeit nach Berlin gegangen und habe da dass Naturkundemuseums geleitet und ja kann man vielleicht schon sagen, wir haben so eine Art Relaunch gemacht. Das war damals an der Humboldt-Universität, es gab gute Gründe. Es ging um Finanzierungen etc., eine neue Struktur zu suchen. Da bin ich also sehr ins Management natürlich dann auch reingekommen. Das gehört heute zur Leibniz-Gemeinschaft, bekommt also Bund- und Landesmittel, was für so eine Institution glaube ich sehr wichtig ist. Bin aber dann danach, weil es an der HU eben jetzt auch nicht Geowissenschaften, also geologische Geowissenschaften gibt, bin ich dann eben an die FU rübergegangen und hatte da schon das Anthropozän in der Tasche.
Schon seit einigen Jahren und dachte, das ist eine gute Möglichkeit, hier nicht nur von meinen Grundkenntnissen aus wieder weiter zu arbeiten, sondern eben das alles, was ich in der ganzen Zeit gemacht habe, also mich in die Biowissenschaften mich hineinbegeben habe, aber auch in die Politikberatung, in die Kommunikation, ins Ausstellungswesen, in visuelle Kommunikation, das in diesen Anthropozänansatz quasi zusammenführen zu können. Und irgendwo fühle ich mich jetzt fast wieder so, als hätte ich es geschafft, damals am Ende der Schule das alles zu integrieren, was mich eigentlich interessiert hat. Also Naturwissenschaften, Sozialkulturwissenschaften, kulturelles insgesamt und deswegen fühle ich mich mit diesem Ansatz des Anthropozäns eigentlich wohl und finde es auch für mich etwas, was gut passt.
Sozusagen ein Thema, in dem alles zusammenkommt, was Sie bisher gemacht haben.
Wo alles mit allem zusammenhängt und auch das irgendwie zusammengeführt wird, was integriert wird, wo ich gewisse Kompetenzen meine zu haben.
Ja dann sollten wir mal eine kleine Definition einschieben, weil der Begriff mag ja nicht jedem so geläufig sein. Anthropozän ist kann man sagen ein Vorschlag für die Benennung des Zeitalters, Erdzeitalters, derer es ja bereits mehrere gegeben hat, nur dass man halt von Erdzeitaltern immer von extrem großen Zeiträumen spricht. Also zumindest aus unserer Perspektive heraus. Und im Anthropozän steckt der Anthro, also der Mensch, wir reden also vom Zeitalter des Menschen. Vielleicht sollten wir mal diese Begrifflichkeit insofern mal etwas aufschlüsseln. Was ist denn die Aufgabe dieser … also eigentlich sind wir ja derzeit im Holozän, es gibt noch diverse andere -zäns, da werde ich jetzt nicht anfangen, die aufzulisten, weil das ist nicht meine Kompetenz.
Aber was sind denn so die wichtigsten Zeitalter, die man so im Blick haben sollte, wenn man irgendwie ein Verständnis dafür hat?
Gut, also vielleicht mal vorneweg geschickt, die Geologen beschäftigen sich mit einer extrem langen Zeit. Die 4,5 Milliarden Jahren, seit es die Erde so in etwas festerer Form auch gibt und sie untersuchen sie weltweit. Also das ist schon eine große Aufgabe. Und das ist natürlich ein extrem diffiziles und differenziertes buntes Spektrum an Gesteinen, an dahinterstehenden Ablagerungsräumen, allem was wir hier im großen Buch der Erdgeschichte überliefert haben. Deswegen gibt es einen Agreement, an das sich eigentlich alle halten, dass wir sagen, wir müssen das soweit aufgliedern, durchaus bürokratisch, dass die Kollegin in China und der Kollege in Brasilien dasselbe darunter versteht, wenn ich von der Jurazeit spreche hier. Also dass wir uns da auf Begriffe einigen. Und nicht nur auf Begriffe, sondern dass wir die auch definieren, dass wir damit gleich Zeiträume meinen.
Und das ist eine ganz lange und vielleicht mit die wichtigste Tradition in der Erdgeschichte, die stratigraphische Untersuchung von Gesteinen. Also was korreliere ich miteinander, kann ich das lokal nur korrelieren oder kann ich das auch global korrelieren? Kann ich hier Zeitlinien relativer Art oder vielleicht dann sogar absoluter Art hier mit reinlegen. Das ist so die Grundwissenschaft in der Geologie, wenn es darum geht, frühere Zeiten zu rekonstruieren.
Stratigraphie heißt das?
Stratigraphie, die Schichtenkunde, wenn Sie so wollen. Und daher wissen wir eben, dass wir, und so hat man es dann gemacht, dass wir verschiedene Ären haben, dass wir ein Protozoikum, ein Archaikum haben, ein Proterozoikum haben. Ein Paläozoikum, ein Mesozoikum, ein Känozoikum. Das wäre so diese Grobeinteilung. Und das wird dann immer weiter möglichst feiner untergliedert, so dass wir etwa im Mesozoikum, eine Triaszeit, eine Jurazeit und eine Kreidezeit haben, die man dann wieder weiter unterteilen kann, bis man eben dann zu möglichst feinen Einheiten kommt. Und das Ganze ist festgehalten oder auch geregelt durch eine sogenannten internationale stratigraphische Kommission. Das ist jetzt nicht an der UN aufgehängt, als ich muss nicht unterschreiben, dass ich mich an diese Regeln halte, aber es macht eben Sinn, das zu machen.
Und es werden immer wieder neue Einheiten aufgestellt, weil die Wissenschaft so weitergegangen ist, dass man etwas weiter untergliedern kann oder weil sich auch etwas nicht bewährt hat. Das Tertiär zum Beispiel, was viele noch kennen, auch aus der Schule, ist eigentlich abgeschafft worden von einem Paläogen und durch Neogen ersetzt worden, hält sich aber die Community nicht so wirklich dran, deswegen diskutiert man jetzt wieder, ob man das wieder reetabliert. Also was ich damit sagen möchte, es sind bürokratische, konservative, lange Prozesse, bevor man sagt, wir müssen da was umdefinieren oder auch etwas neu definieren. Die Einheiten werde nach oben eigentlich nachvollziehbarerweise immer kürzer. Die letzt Einheit, die wir haben, das Holozän, ist nur 12.000 Jahre alt. Aber das liegt auch daran, dass eben da die Sedimente noch jünger sind, da noch mehr Kriterien drin sind, die uns helfen können, da noch feinere Zeitlinien reinzutun. Was aber nicht heißt, dass wir nicht auch schon früher immer mal eine ganz hohe Auflösung erreichen können.
Der Meteoriteneinschlag an der Kreide-Tertiär-Grenze war sicherlich eine sehr kurze Sache. Wir können aber auch Saisonalitäten sogar Jahre oder manchmal sogar in Sedimenten sogenannte Gezeitenbündel, also Mondphasen, noch erkennen aus Jahrmillionen Jahre alten Sedimenten. Also unser Bestreben ist schon, möglichst gute Auflösung zu erreichen. Das wäre jetzt mal so das Allgemeine hier. Und vielleicht zu den Namen, weil Sie sie angesprochen haben, so dieses Känozoikum, also diese letzte große Ära, die wird unterteilt in Namen wie Paläozän, Eozän, Oligozän, Miozän, Pliozän, Pleistozän, das wären dann die letzen Eiszeiten und eben das Holozän. Und wenn man sich die Begriffe dann mal anschaut, dann muss ich mal ehrlicherweise sagen, dass die Stratigraphen jetzt nicht wirklich die Oberkreativsten sind. Denn so übersetzt heißt das Paläozän das alte Neue und dann vielleicht Eozän das aufgehende Neue, dann kommt das schwache Neue, das kleine Neue, das mehr Neue, das am meisten Neue und das Holozän ist das völlig Neue.
Und wenn dann ein Anthropozän noch kommt, dann ist das ja schon fast ein großer Fortschritt, wenn man das nämlich genau übersetzt ist das das menschengemachte Neue.
Ja und sehr konkret in gewisser Sicht.
Und schon recht konkret. Aber vielleicht darf ich es noch historisch kurz erläutern, wie es zu diesem Begriff kam.
Nur um das nochmal zu verstehen. Ich blicke da gerade drauf, also grundsätzlich diese ganze Strukturierung der Zeit ist so auch so in verschiedene Gruppen aufgeteilt. Also ich glaube man spricht von Äons für die ganz großen Klammern. Darin wiederum Ären und darin noch so Systeme.
Ja Systeme, wenn wir die Sedimente meinen, Periode, wenn wir die Zeit meinen. Also auch das wird noch so ein bisschen unterschieden.
Und das was sozusagen auf -zän endet, das ist sozusagen in dieser aktuellen Ära.
Das wären die Epochen, die jetzt in der jüngeren Zeit sind, die alle auf -zän hinten enden.
Genau.
Also eine recht kleine Einheit eigentlich. Es gibt noch kleinere, aber um das geht es hier. Und tatsächlich kommt nun, und das stört vielleicht manchen in den Geowissenschaften, bei den Geologen kommt dieser Begriff jetzt nicht unbedingt von der Geologie. Es gibt zwar so Vorläufer. Es ist mal von Stoppani einem Geologen im 19. Jahrhundert das Anthropozoikum benannt worden. Ist dann aber wieder verschwunden und es waren die Erdsystemwissenschaftler, sich im Jahr 2000 mal wieder getroffen haben, die dann wieder diskutieren, ob das Erdsystem noch so ist, wie es früher auch war. Wie es mit dem Klimawandel vorangegangen ist, wie die Landnutzung ist, wie die Ozeansituation ist. Und da hat Paul Crutzen, der Nobelpreisträger, den wir ja alle kennen, aufgrund seiner Arbeiten zum Ozonloch.
Und auch der Hilfe dann übrigens des Montreal-Protokoll auf UN-Ebene zu erreichen, so dass das nicht mehr zu unseren ganz großen Problemen gehört. Er ist einer dieser Erdsystemforscher und er war auf dieser denkwürdigen Tagung 2000 in Mexiko dabei, wo das wieder aufgezählt wurde und er hat quasi einen Zwischenruf gemacht und gesagt, also Leute wir leben doch nicht mehr im Holozän, sondern wir leben im Anthro- er hat also quasi nach einem Wort gesucht, im Anthropozän und dann war dieses Wort in der Welt und damit hat er aber auch eine These aufgestellt, dass eben genügend viel geologische Signaturen da sein sollten, um so etwas neu zu definieren. Also man kann sich diesem Anthropozän mit Thesen nähern. Die erste These war die der Erdsystemwissenschaftler. Das heutige Erdsystem hat nichts mehr zu tun mit dem stabilen Erdsystem, was wir währen des Holozäns hatten. Was auch die Grundlage dafür war, dass wir uns niederlassen konnten, dass wir mit Saisonalitäten rechnen konnten.
Dass wir Landwirtschaft betreiben konnten in der neolithischen Revolution. Dass wir Städte gründen konnten, die Sie an einen Fluss machen. Dass würden Sie nicht machen, wenn Sie sich ganz sicher sind, dass der nächstes Jahr eh nicht mehr da ist, weil das Klima völlig schräg ist.
Also ist quasi eine Stabilisierung des Erdklimas.
Es war in dieser Zeit eine wirklich über 10.000 Jahre eine Stabilisierung des Erdklimas, der Zuverlässigkeit, also eine Regelmäßigkeit oder ein gutes Gleichgewichtsverhalten von sonstigen erdsystemischen Prozessen.
Und damit auch eine Vorhersagbarkeit.
Eine Vorhersagbarkeit, die uns die Industrialisierung auch nicht ermöglicht hätte, weil wir Infrastrukturen aufbauen. Handel, Eisenbahnen. Sie bauen keine Eisenbahn, wenn Sie nicht sagen können, ob da ein Wirbelsturm nächstes Jahr kommt oder nicht. Also das war glaube ich schon sehr wichtig. Also diese These kann nach allem was wir wissen, Klimawandel als ein Beispiel nur genannt, aber auch die starke Änderung der Erdoberfläche nur noch ein Viertel der eisfreien Erdoberfläche können wir als Natur, als Urnatur bezeichnen. Alles andere sind schon menschengemachte oder stark menschenbeeinflusste Räume. Wir sprechen nicht mehr von Biomen, sondern von Anthromen. Also diese These kann bejaht werden. Daraus eben jetzt die Frage an die Geologen, seht ihr das? Auch in den Sedimenten, müssten eure Sedimente denn nicht anders aussehen? Also das ist das, wo jetzt die Geologen, auch ich, daran arbeiten.
In dieser internationalen Gruppe, die dazu einberufen wurde von dieser internationalen stratigraphischen Kommission, da gibt es eine Arbeitsgruppe, The Anthropocene Working Group, in der vor allem Geologen, aber sonst auch Erdsystemwissenschaftler, aber auch Archäologen bis hin zu einem Umweltjuristen und Historikern daran arbeiten, nachzuschauen, gibt es hier geologische Signaturen? Und wir tragen die zusammen und sagen, ja es gibt sie. Es gibt neue Arten von Fossilien, Plastik, Beton, elementares Aluminium, Flugasche aus industriellen Prozessen, die wir als solche noch erkennen können. Wir haben sonstige natürlich geochemische Signale, die anders sind. Wir haben polyaromatische Kohlenwasserstoffe, Biphenyle, Pestizide, Rückstoffe. Wir haben ganz veränderte Verhältnisse von Stickstoff und Phosphor im Boden. Und wir finden überall Industriemetalle. Wir sprechen da richtig von Pfeffermetallen oder Spicy Metals.
Die wie mit dem Pfefferstreuer die Würzmetalle, die mit einem Pfefferstreuer überall verteilen werden, weil wir eben punktuell ganz spezielle seltene Erden etc. gewinnen, die aber nicht wirklich im System halten und die irgendwie durch schlechtes Recycling, oder fehlendes Recycling irgendwie gleich verteilt werden. Also das sehen wir in den Sedimenten und deswegen sind wir der Meinung, ja es macht Sinn, so eine neue Epoche auszurufen. Die Frage ist, wie man sie definiert. Wo ist die Untergrenze ganz genau? Können wir gerne noch drüber weiterreden, da gibt es viel und wichtige Diskussionen dazu natürlich auch. Das Kriterium für uns wäre, ab wann sehen wir das global und möglichst synchron, also eindeutig, so dass wir es wirklich wieder verwenden können als Leitlinie, als Korrelationshorizont, diese Untergrenze.
Weil letztlich müssen sich ja auch alle drauf einigen.
Und es muss sozusagen ja auch nicht nur ausgerufen werden, quasi als politischer Diskussionsbegriff, der es auch ist, wo wir sicherlich auch noch drauf kommen. Aber zunächst einmal muss es ja auch sich quasi geologisch auch konkret manifestieren, dass man sagen kann, guck mal bis hier war so und dann war es auf einmal irgendwie anders. Weil jetzt auf einmal Dinge in Bewegung kommen, die vorher durch Gezeiten, vulkanische Aktivität, wodurch auch immer und Temperaturschwankungen über längere Zeiträume sich in Bewegung gebracht haben und jetzt haben wir da also ein freidrehendes Lebewesen, was alles mögliche aus der Erde herausholt und in die Luft schmeißt und damit quasi quer über den ganzen Planeten verteilt.
Müssen sich alle drauf einigen genau.
Genau so ist es. Also bevor wir dann zu der dritten Ebene kommen, ich nenne das die Metaebene, was bedeutet es denn, wenn wir in einem neuen geologischen Zeitalter sind für Verantwortung, wie wir weiter machen …
Die dritte Ebene wovon jetzt?
Dieses Anthropozän-Konzepts. Also die erste Ebene ist die erdsystemische Betrachtung. Das Erdsystem ist anders.
Also Erdsystem im Sinne von was wir gerade eben besprochen haben. Verteilung der Materialien?
Also Klimawandel, Landnutzung, das sind alles Dinge, die ich jetzt nicht automatisch sofort in der Geologie sehe in den Sedimenten, sondern das ist der heutige Zustand der Erde. Klimawandel, Ozeanströmungen, Landnutzungen, eben alle diese Dinge. Auch wie wir eingreifen in Sedimentationsverhalten übrigens. Unsere Deltas wachsen ja nicht mehr, weil wir zuvor in Stauseen die ganzen Sedimente abfangen, die da rausholen, vielleicht schon auch verbauen.
Und den Sand aus dem Meer auch noch abbaggern, damit wir unsere Gebäude bauen können.
Den Sand aus dem Meer auch noch abbaggern und uns dann noch weitere Probleme einhandeln. Das wäre so diese erdsystematische Betrachtung, wo die Erdsystemleute sagen, ja wir müssen heute das Erdsystem nicht nur betrachten als zusammengesetzt von einer Lithosphäre, einer Petosphäre, also dem Boden, einer Hydrosphäre, also Wasser, einer Biosphäre und noch einer Atmosphäre, sondern wir müssen eine Anthroposphäre noch dazu denken oder die Soziosphären, weil das alles eben ineinander agiert. Und weil wir eben ein Erdsystemfaktor geworden sind.  Und die zweite These ist, sehen wir das in den Sedimenten? Dann sagen wir, ja. Also wir sind auch ein geologischer Faktor geworden, der sich da niederschlägt mit diesen neuen Signalen, mit diesen neuen Materialien, Plastik und so.
Das ist jetzt quasi die zweite Ebene?
Das ist die zweite Ebene und die dritte Ebene ist dann, genügt uns dieser Befund, reicht es den Wissenschaften mal wieder? Bleiben die da in ihrem Elfenbeinturm drin sitzen oder könnten wir da vielleicht auch irgendeine Lehre daraus ziehen? Die könnte doch sein wieder eine These, wenn wir schon einen derartigen Einfluss aufs Erdsystem haben und wenn wir schon mehr oder weniger unwissentlich erst mal das so geändert haben, dann müsste es doch wissenschaftsbasiert aber auch mit sonstigem Wissen eingetragen möglich sein, in vorsichtiger Weise so etwas wie wissenschaftsgärtnerisch ranzugehen und die Zukunft der Erde auch so zu gestalten, dass wir ein funktionsfähiges Erdsystem wieder bekommen, wenn es die Menschheit mit integriert. Und wenn ich es jetzt so ein bisschen zugespitzt sage, dann müssten wir eigentlich lernen, dass wir vom Parasitismus, den wir so gerade haben mit der Erde.
Wir holen einfach alles raus, maximieren das und was wir jetzt haben, haben wir schon mal und so weiter. Denken wirklich nicht groß an die zukünftigen Generationen und an sonstige Generationengerechtigkeit. Wir müssen also von diesem parasitischen Handeln zum symbiotischen Handeln kommen. Müssten uns also integrieren in dieses Erdsystem. Und das würde aber auch so ein bisschen bedeuten, dass wir vieles ganz neu denken müssen. Dass wir von Dualismen wegkommen, hier ist die Natur, da ist die Kultur. Das Anthropozän-Konzept zeigt uns, stimmt gar nicht mehr so. Wir müssen auch wegkommen zu sagen, das ist richtig und das ist falsch, das ist gut und das ist schlecht und das hilft uns oft nicht mehr, diese Zuspitzung. Wir wissen oft, ja so geht es nicht weiter. Also muss es so sein. Und da streiten wir uns und meinen, da ist nur diese eine richtige Lösung drin, das gibt es wahrscheinlich nicht, sondern wir müssen auch da systemischer rangehen und offener rangehen und verschiedene Visionen verhandeln und uns Dinge besser vorstellen können.
Also das ist das was ich so als Metaebene bezeichne. Aber wir waren ja noch bei der Geologie. Ich habe jetzt Ihre Frage nicht so ganz richtig beantwortet. Also die Frage ist ja innerhalb der Geologie, worauf einigen wir uns, wo geht dieses Anthropozän los? Soll ich da noch ein bisschen erläutern?
Ich fasse mal kurz nochmal zusammen. Also grundsätzlich wir haben gelernt, es gibt halt diese Kategorisierung, die ja auch für die wissenschaftliche Arbeit an sich sehr wichtig ist, damit man einfach eine Grundlage hat, Referenzmodelle auch hat, auf die an sich eben bezieht, um die eigene wissenschaftliche Arbeit auch immer im richtigen Kontext auch deuten zu können. Jetzt kam 2000 eben dieser Vorstoß, dieser neue Gedanke im Prinzip so, hör mal so viel hat sich verändert und so viel wird sich auch in absehbarer Zeit noch sehr nachhaltig verändern. Nicht nachhaltig im Sinne wie es der Erde gut täte, sondern dass es sozusagen erst mal ohne weiteres sich auch nicht stoppen lässt. Und man kann es sehen am Wandel des Klimas und an anderen Parametern. Man sieht es aber auch konkret an seinem geologischen Niederschlag, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes. Und es erzwingt vor allem auch ein gesellschaftspolitisches Umdenken.
So dass sozusagen auch eine über die technisch-wissenschaftliche Perspektive hinaus Notwendigkeit einer Neudefinition eines Begriffs dasteht, auch um sozusagen eine neue Debatte damit führen zu können. So habe ich das jetzt zunächst einmal verstanden. So das sind sozusagen diese drei Eckpfeiler. Wie akzeptiert und etabliert ist denn dieser Begriff bereits? Ist das sozusagen schon durch oder muss es da wie beim Pluto seinerseits so eine Konferenz geben, wo man sagt, okay ist kein Planet mehr. Wer definiert denn diese ganzen -zoiken und -zäne?
Also es ist nicht durch, aber der Begriff ist in der Welt und wird ziemlich sicher auch bleiben. Die Frage ist eben nur, in welchem Kontext er diskutiert wird. Und es gibt Kritik von allen möglichen Seiten, die ist auch wichtig. Und da ist es aber glaube ich auch wichtig, die Kritik zu kanalisieren. Geht es darum, um die Frage ….
Was für Kritik ist es denn?
Brauchen wir das überhaupt? Also so in den Geowissenschaften. Was ist da der Mehrwert dabei, auch der wissenschaftliche Mehrwert? Oder es gibt eine andere Kritik, die sagt, das ist zu politisch das ganze Konzept. Es gibt wieder andere, die sagen, es ist zu wenig politisch. Das ist ja wieder nur so eine stratigraphische Sache irgendwie. Also das kommt aber dann auf einer Metaebene quasi. Es gibt eigentlich von allen Communities gibt es ganz enthusiastische Befürworter und auch eine große Ablehnung. Bei Naturschutzverbänden etwa, manche sagen, das ist jetzt eigentlich die Lösung, wir können die Dinge viel besser zusammen denken. Die anderen sagen, halt halt, da soll vielleicht Geoengineering durch die Hintertür nur hereinkommen. Oder wir haben das immer, das ist ja nur ein neues Wort für Sachen, die wir eh schon machen. Soziologen sind kräftig dabei auch, mit dem Anthropoiden-Effekt zu arbeiten. Es gibt aber auch welche, die sagen, Moment mal, die wollen uns die Dualismen und die Dialektik wegnehmen.
Wir sind gewöhnt und das ist im Prinzip unsere Kultur, diese Wissenschaftskultur, dass wir zuspitzen eben auf dialektische Entscheidungen oder Pro und Contra. Also so könnte ich das eigentlich weitermachen. Und bei den Geowissenschaften gibt es diejenigen, die sagen, wir haben doch schon immer in der Quartärgeologie, also in der Geologie des Heute auch irgendwie Industriehalden auskartiert, weggehalten, das kennen wir doch schon alles, das braucht man doch gar nicht. Das verkennt natürlich dann, dass es jetzt uns nicht nur um den Teufelsberg etwa hier in Berlin geht. Der tatsächlich eine Aufschüttung seit 1950 ist, wo also ein Großteil des zerbombten Berlins eben drin liegt. Eine echte anthropozäne geologische Einheit, wenn Sie so wollen. Sondern es geht darum, dass wir halt das Mikroplastik in Hochgebirgsseen genauso wie in der Tiefsee finden.
Also dass es auch in den „natürlichen Sedimenten“ überall dieses Signal gibt. Und Historiker, die auch sehr einerseits, also eine Community, die das sehr begrüßt das Konzept, gibt es andere, die sagen, naja wir haben doch in diesen jungen Zeiten, da haben wir doch die Jahreszahlen, damit können wir doch auch gut arbeiten, wieso brauchen wir da jetzt eine geologische Einheit? Und da kann man drauf antworten, ja aber Historiker und überhaupt auch Umweltmonitoring etc. notiert nur, schreibt nur auf, worauf man ein Augenmerk richtet. Historiker recherchieren durch ihre Quellen, ob das Anlandungen von Fischen sind, wenn es Umwelthistoriker sind oder so etwas hier. Die NASA macht heute irgendwo Satelliten, aber auch gezielt mit einer bestimmten Vorstellung, wo da was überwacht werden soll und die Natur macht es einfach so. Also die zeichnet uns Dinge auf, von denen wir nie gedacht hätten, dass wir da vielleicht irgendwas angestellt haben.
Und das bringt eben die Skalen schon sehr gut zusammen, dass sie eine geologische Zeitskala zusammenbringen mit historischen Skalen. Das wäre der eine Vorteil, den ich hier sehe. Das zweite ist, dass wir auch lernen müssen, dass wir in dem kurzen Jetzt, was wir jetzt haben, auf der individuellen und auf der gesellschaftlichen Ebene, dass wir hier Dinge auslösen, die lange lange lange geologisch lange Nachwirkungen haben. Wir können da vom Phänomen des langen Jetzt sprechen. Herr Schellenhuber hat mal von der Diktatur des Jetzt gesprochen. Also was wir jetzt machen, selbst wenn wir es jetzt wieder abstellen würden, wenn wir ab morgen keinen fossilen Kohlenstoff mehr ausstoßen würden. Es wird noch über tausende von Jahren Nachwirkungen geben. Bei Atommüll noch teilweise bis zu Millionen von Jahren. Bei Organismen, die verschwunden sind, können es auch Millionen sein, bis adäquates durch die Evolution wieder ersetzt wäre.
Also wir müssen diese Skalenverschränkungen lernen, auch wenn wir nach vorne schauen. Das ist glaube ich wichtig.
Da fallen mir gerade so viele Sachen zu ein. Bevor wir vielleicht nochmal im Nachgang noch ein bisschen auf diese damit verbundene politische Dimension kommen, würde ich vielleicht gerne mal vertiefen. Was lässt sich quasi konkret als Beleg auch anführen, um dieses Anthropozän auszurufen. Und vor allem wann fängt es denn eigentlich an? Also wann hat es denn angefangen? Wenn das Holozän jetzt 12.000 Jahre gehalten hat, wir blicken hier sicherlich nicht auf 1.000 Jahre zurück, sondern auf einen sehr sehr viel kürzeren Zeitraum.
Ich bin Ihnen noch eine Antwort schuldig, die Frage, wer definiert das dann. Also die kann ich nur beantworten für die Geologen. Das ist ja mal so die hauptdiskutierte Gretchenfrage, kommt diese Zeit als formale Einheit in diese geologische Zeitskala mit rein? Und dafür zuständig ist die International Union of Geological Sciences, der Dachverband aller geologischen Vereinigungen aus der ganzen Welt. Und da ist die größte Untereinheit diese International Commission for Stratigraphy. Und die hat Unterkommissionen, etwa auch für das Quartär und diese Unterkommissionen können Arbeitsgruppen einsetzen, falls es da neue Ideen gibt und die hat tatsächlich diese stratigraphische Kommission, gemeinsam mit dieser Unterkommission Quartär die Arbeitsgruppe eingesetzt, Working Group on the Anthropocene.
Und da soll ein Vorschlag gemacht werden, also soll eine breite Diskussion geführt werden, pro und contra einerseits, ob es Sinn macht, so was zu definieren. Und falls ja, wo die Untergrenze liegen könnte. Und diese Kommission gibt es glaube ich seit 2008. Ich bin seit 2013 dabei und wir treffen uns immer wieder mal, sind ansonsten aber im direkten Austausch. Wir publizieren viel, indem wir zusammentragen, was es da an Kriterien gibt. Und wir haben jetzt auf dem Weltkongress der Geologen, der jetzt Ende August in Kapstadt war, nun die ersten Ergebnisse vorgestellt und haben noch kein Proposal. Man muss ein offizielles Proposal mal machen. Wir haben jetzt eine Grundfrage geklärt. Soll man sich ganz klassisch an die Standardmethoden halten der Geologen, dann muss man dann nämlich ein sogenanntes Typusprofil irgendwo finden, wo man sagt, hier kann man diese Grenze am besten definieren.
Da wird dann ein Golden Spike, ein goldener Nagel sogar eingeschlagen, also er kann eingeschlagen werden. Und das ist so ähnlich wie wenn Sie eine neue Art entdecken, wo Sie eine Typusart, einen sogenannten Holotypus irgendwo hinterlegen müssen in einem Museum, wo jeder Wissenschaftler sich das als Referenz anschauen kann. So gibt es das in der Geologie als Typusprofile. Und es gibt eine andere Möglichkeit, eine andere, einfach nur einen Zeitpunkt zu nennen und zu sagen, ab da sei das Anthropozän und da wurde jetzt nun mehrheitlich gesagt, auch innerhalb der Gruppe, nein das wollen wir eigentlich nicht. Es gab große Diskussionen, es gab Abstimmungen. In unserer Gruppe ist es so dass von 35 Leuten 34 dafür sind, das formal zu definieren. Und eine Enthaltung, also keine Gegenstimme. Da ging es nur darum, wo es dann genauer liegen soll. Und ich schätze, wir haben jetzt den Auftrag, also a) zu testen, dass man es wirklich global korrelieren kann alles.
Und b) dann so ein Vorschlag für so ein Typusprofil zu machen. Und ich schätze, es dauert noch 2-4 Jahre, bis es dann formell abgestimmt wird.
Konkret auch mit einem Zeitpunkt?
Auch konkret mit einem Zeitpunkt.
Was ist so der heiße Kandidat für einen Zeitpunkt?
Also da wurde, auch da ein kurzer Abriss, Paul Crutzen, von dem ja der Begriff stammt, der hat erst mal gesagt, eigentlich war es die Dampfmaschine, also die Optimierung der Dampfmaschine, von James Watts, so kurz vor 1800, da sollte das Anthropozän losgehen. Er ist inzwischen mit uns der Meinung, ja dieses Durchstarten der Industrialisierung war wesentlich, damit es zu einem Anthropozän kommt, aber wir haben so eine Lagzeit, Verzögerung …
Auswirkungen kamen erst später.
… bis wir es dann auch wirklich in den Sedimenten sehen.
Hätte man 50 Jahre später alles wieder abgeschaltet, wäre wahrscheinlich nicht viel passiert.
So genau in dieser Richtung. Es gibt andere, oft auch so mehr von den Biologen und Ökologen kommend, die sagen, eigentlich war es doch die neolithische Revolution. Also das sich Niederlassen der Menschheit.
Jungsteinzeit?
Jungsteinzeit. Manche sagen auch sogar noch älter. Als wir das Großwild gejagt haben, da wären wir noch im Pleistozän in den Eiszeiten. Das hätte doch schon Einschnitte gemacht. Oder dann die ganzen Stadtgründungen, da sagen wir, ja da war der Mensch schon kräftig aktiv. Das kann man vielleicht auch im einen oder anderen Fall ganz gut sehen, aber das hat sich über tausende von Jahren hingezogen. Es ist uns also nicht synchron genug das Ganze. Und es gab lokale und regionale Effekte, aber noch nicht eben einen global messbaren Effekt. Das wird diskutiert. Es gibt den ein oder anderen Spike beim CO2, wo man sagen kann, das ist offensichtlich global. Aber ob das dann wiederum der Mensch war oder die natürliche Fluktuation, das ist schwer zu entscheiden. Und deswegen sind wir inzwischen der Meinung, dass wir was nehmen sollten, wo wir möglichst viele Kriterien haben.
Und es wäre eigentlich das, was in der Wissenschaft auch als die große Beschleunigung von Prozessen in der Natur, Veränderungsprozessen in der Natur, aber auch in der Gesellschaft genannt wird. Das wäre also um Mitte des 20. Jahrhunderts. So nach dem Krieg, so 1950. Und da kommen eben zum einen Atombombenversuche dazu. Da kommt das Durchstarten von Plastik dazu. Plastik gab es zwar schon vor dem Krieg, so mit Bakelit und so etwas, aber minimal. Es wurde dann im Krieg richtig weiterentwickelt. Eigentlich weil Porzellan für die Feldküchen zu schwer war. Es ging dann danach los mit Nylonstrümpfen, mit Hulahoop-Reifen und allem möglichen, bis dann aber die Verpackungen dazu kamen relativ schnell. Und wir produzieren heute fast so viel Plastik pro Jahr, wie es der Biomasse der ganzen Menschheit entspricht und schmeißen jede Minute, in der wir hier reden, quasi einen Lastwagen voll ins Meer an Plastik.
Also das meine ich mit diesem Durchstarten hier. Und auch das Aluminium, was es schon ein bisschen früher gab, und auch Beton, was es eigentlich schon seit der Römerzeit gab, da haben wir 80% des Betons in den letzten 20 Jahren produziert. Also wir sehen das da am besten. Und wir haben dann eben ein großes Spektrum von Kriterien, die ich ja schon eben zum guten Teil auch genannt habe, die sehr gut passen um diesen Zeitraum von 1950.
Also das ist sozusagen der heiße Kandidat?
Das ist jetzt der heiße Kandidat gerade. Und da waren eben 34 von 35 jetzt auch dafür, den zu nehmen.
Jetzt hatten Sie ja vorhin angesprochen, dass das ja auch eine gesellschaftspolitische Dimension hat. Dass man hier nicht nur rein geologisch, meteorologisch und welche anderen wissenschaftlichen Disziplinen hier alle noch quasi mit reingezogen werden müssen, um da auch ein zumindest vorläufig abschließendes Bild zu liefern, ist es quasi auch ein Teil der Botschaft an dieser Stelle, auch etwas festzumachen. Wenn man sagen kann, hier die Veränderung ist real, die Veränderung ist umfangreich, die Veränderung ist sehr langfristig. Sie hat sogar schon, wenn man die Radioaktivität mit reinnimmt, das Potenzial, die Menschheit zu überdauern. Das ist ja dann eigentlich auch mal eine ganz andere Positionierung der Wissenschaft, als man das vielleicht bisher gehabt hat.
Und wenn man da mal so ein bisschen, wenn man mal die Zeitalter der Wissenschaft mal ganz lax aufklappen würde. Ich sehe das so, dass es ja eigentlich erst so vor 100-150 Jahren vielleicht diese Wissenschaft als solche überhaupt erst geschafft hat, sich zu etablieren. Dass Leute sagen konnten, mein Beruf ist Wissenschaftler und nicht nur, ich habe irgendeinen Beruf und nebenbei schaffe ich auch Wissen. Sondern dass man quasi überhaupt von einer Wissenschaft als solcher sprechen kann, deren Bedeutung dann schnell angestiegen ist. Vielleicht auch gerade so zum Beginn dieses Anthropozäns dann auch so wegweisend war, ja auch selber in gewisser Hinsicht auch der Inbegriff dieser Zukunftsliebe war. Gerade nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg, wo die Wissenschaft so als der Faktor des Aufbruchs, die Industrialisierung, die Verwirklichung der Träume, macht man sich ja wenig klar, wie viele grundlegende Probleme der Menschheit, wie Nahrungsmittelversorgung etc., Transport und so weiter durch Energieversorgung, durch wissenschaftliche Durchbrüche ja im Prinzip überhaupt erst möglich geworden ist.
Und jetzt sind wir in so einem merkwürdigen Zustand gerade, wo ich sehe, dass die Wissenschaft auf der einen Seite diese unbestreitbare Basis eigentlich der gesamten technischen und damit auch der menschlichen Entwicklung ist, auf der anderen Seite aber auch so ein Zweifel auf einmal im Raum haben. Ich meine wir sprechen hier November 2016 mit den großen politischen Umbrüchen, die sich gerade in den USA abzeichnen und damit auch verbunden die – kann man schon fast sagen – Machtergreifung von so antiwissenschaftlichem Grunddenken. Und jetzt kommt man mit so einem Begriff daher und möchte quasi sagen, wir müssen jetzt Wissenschaft wirklich als festen Bestandteil der gesellschaftspolitischen Diskussion und der gesellschaftlichen Weiterentwicklung definieren. Nicht nur mit diesem Begriff, aber unter anderem auch durch diesen Begriff.
Kann man sagen, dass auch die Wissenschaft hier in ein neues Zeitalter eintritt?
Ich denke schon. Ich hoffe es. Also zum einen sind glaube ich die Zeiten vorbei, wo man nur hehre Wissenschaft im Elfenbeinturm gemacht hat. Und das mögen vielleicht nicht alle gerne hören, aber wenn ich jetzt die Geologen anschaue, die sind zu einem guten Teil auch mit dran schuld, dass es ein Anthropozän gibt, denn sie haben das Erdöl erst mal gefunden. Und aufgefunden, was über hunderte von Millionen Jahren quasi von der Natur weggepackt wurde als Biomasse. Und heute füttern wir quasi die Maschinen damit, die also auch essen müssen, wenn Sie so wollen, wenn wir bei so einem Narrativ hier bleiben wollen. Also das ist glaube ich wichtig. Es ist jetzt keine Rede gegen sektorale Wissenschaften und auch gegen Freiräume in den Wissenschaften, die wir weiterhin brauchen werden. Aber wir brauchen wieder mehr so verbindende Wissenschaften auch. Ein Humboldt hat so was mal gemacht.
Hat eben Natur und Kultur und Dinge zusammengebracht. Und ich glaube das ist eine Ressource, wenn wir das richtig machen, zusammenfügen, wo wir auch stolz drauf sein können.
Also Verbindungen nicht nur innerhalb der Disziplin, also nicht nur interdisziplinäre Verbindungen, sondern Verbindungen mit der Gesellschaft?
Auch, also das eine wäre erst mal echt interdisziplinär, nicht nur so multidisziplinär, wir haben hier ein Phänomen und jeder schaut mal aus seiner Sparte drauf, sondern man hat gemeinsame Fragestellungen. Wir wollen ein, was kann die Wissenschaft beitragen, um ein funktionsfähiges Anthropozän für die Zukunft helfen zu generieren. Aber dann eben auch transdisziplinär, also wo die Gesellschaft mit eingebaut wird. Also vielleicht auch, damit das wirklich ganz klar ist, die Wissenschaft, wenn wir zurückschauen auf die Wissenschaft, was die Wissenschaften geleistet haben, ich möchte das unterstreichen, was Sie gesagt haben, dann ist es ja auch eine Ermutigung, dass man eben jetzt, wo wir genügend viel Wissen haben, es doch schaffen könnte, zu einer neuen Gestaltung der Welt zu kommen. Aber das werden die Wissenschaften alleine nicht schaffen. Und ich glaube auch, wenn wir von einer Wissensgesellschaft reden, die Frage, ob wir die wirklich derzeit haben, ist nochmals eine andere, dann ist es eben nicht nur wissenschaftliches Wissen, sondern wir müssen eben auch Erfahrungswissen mit einbringen.
Und da gibt es eben ganz viel Überzeugungswissen und leider auch Überzeugungen, die halt oft, sehen wir auch gerade heute, emotional gepeitscht werden oder überhaupt erst generiert werden, auch damit müssen wir lernen umzugehen, glaube ich. Was keine leichte Aufgabe sein wird. Wir müssen also, um ein zukunftsfähiges Anthropozän zu gestalten, auch den Menschen noch besser verstehen lernen. Es ist also durchaus auch eine große Aufgabe an psychologische Wissenschaften, Sozialwissenschaften und alles was da noch so mit drinsteckt hier. Das ist das eine. Wir müssen zum Beispiel lernen, dass wir hervorragend sind in Selbstentschuldigungen, da nehmen ich mich nicht aus. Also da geht es jetzt gar nicht nur um Ablehnung der Wissenschaften, sondern Sie können auch sagen, eigentlich müsste ich ja vielleicht was tun, aber warten wir doch lieber erst, bis wir eine ordentliche Technik bekommen. Wir wollen ja keine Verspargelung der Landschaft. Sprich, ich möchte nicht das Windkraftrad neben mir stehen haben, also warten wir doch auf die Kernfusion.
Dann muss die Wissenschaft sagen, ja wir forschen daran weiter, aber es ist zu spät, auf so etwas zu warten, wir müssen jetzt schon was machen. Und vielleicht ist es eine Technologie, die wir dann wieder abbauen werden, wenn wir doch nochmal was anderes haben. Das wäre die eine Sache. Die andere Selbstentschuldigung, die auch alle kennen, ist eh schon zu spät, so was fatalistisches. Oder was kann ich alleine da dagegen tun? Das ist auch eine schwierige Sache. Und so könnte ich das noch weiterspinnen. Es gibt so, ich würde was tun, aber … das ist so die Tragik der Almende. Aber wenn ich mein Haus dämme, dann dämme ich ja die Hälfte vom Nachbarn mit und der beteiligt sich gar nicht, das sehe ich überhaupt nicht ein. Also da sind wir schon ganz gut mit Selbstentschuldigungen.
Ja, wobei Sie da ja die ganze Gesellschaft jetzt mit einbeziehen. Wenn wir jetzt mal nur die Wissenschaft und wissenschaftliche Sphäre/Szene nimmt, denken Sie, dass das an der Stelle schon gut vorankommt? Weil das wäre ja nun noch die Voraussetzung, dass man sich da auch gemeinsam aufstellt.
Die Wissenschaft, wenn wir jetzt in die Zukunft denken, eine Aufgabe der Wissenschaften wird sein zu sagen, das machen eben auch die Erdsystemwissenschaftler, aber auch andere, was sind Wahrscheinlichkeiten für die Zukunft. Vor allem wenn wir so Business as usual weitermachen. Das ist eine wissenschaftliche Aufgabe, da Szenarien zu entwickeln etc. Das ist was IPCC macht, aber auch viele andere natürlich.
Also die Klimakonferenz.
Nicht nur Klima, es geht überhaupt um, wie können wir unsere …
Nein ich meine die IPCC, die Sie gerade zitierten, ist die Klimakommission.
Ja genau, aber auch wenn es heißt, die Digitalisierung die kommt jetzt einfach hier, dann ist das also eine wahrscheinliche Zukunft. Vielleicht gibt es andere mögliche Zukünfte, auch da müssen wir noch stärker rangehen und dann müssen wir bei den möglichen Zukünften auch noch schauen, was sind denn da wünschbare Zukünfte. Und da einen Konsens zu finden, da muss Wissenschaft sich mit Gesellschaft sehr stark auseinandersetzen. Nicht alle wünschbaren Zukünfte sind vielleicht Zukünfte, die ein funktionsfähiges anthropozänes Erdsystem gewährleisten könnten, sondern das muss dann wieder geframed werden von den Planetary Boundaries und den Global Sustainable Goals, die jetzt verabschieden wurden hier. Also das ist schon eine gewaltige Aufgabe. Aber auch eine spannende, eine reizvolle Aufgabe. Weil sie auch sehr kreativ ist. Und ich glaube, auch aus eigener Erfahrung, dass es nicht reicht, dass wir uns nur was wünschen können, was wir uns auch vorstellen können und das ist so eine gewissen Crux.
Weil alles was wir … wir wünschen uns immer das, da gibt es ja auch viel Wünscheforschung, was schon irgendjemand hat, das will man dann auch haben. In den 50er Jahren war das die Waschmaschine oder das Auto, das Einfamilienhaus.
Kühlschrank.
Und Kühlschrank und solche Sachen. Und sich jetzt vorzustellen, wie könnte es denn sein? Dann braucht man Visionäre, aber nicht nur die, sondern man muss das auch etwa in Ausstellungen oder in anderen Formaten, auch deswegen machen wir zum Beispiel Comics, um mal solche Dinge in einer leichten Weise vorwegzunehmen, das mal visualisieren zu können und vor allem muss man es ausprobieren können in einem gewissen Umfang, oder selbst daran mitarbeiten. Deswegen sind so Bewegungen, jetzt komme ich relativ stark von der Wissenschaft weg, erst mal wie Urban Gardening könnte das sein oder auch Labore, in denen man … also von Repair Cafés angefangen bis hin zu Hackerräumen gegebenenfalls. Also Biohacking oder so etwas hier. Aber auch ganz einfache Sachen. Ich probiere mal Insekten aus. Wir versuchen das mal, auch wissenschaftlich übrigens. Wir beforschen das dann auch, wie die Leute reagieren.
Denn Insekten wäre ja zum Beispiel eine potenzielle Zukunftsoption bei der Ernährung. Zwei Milliarden Menschen essen Insekten auf dieser Welt. Insekten sind ganz leicht züchtbar, brauchen im Schnitt so ein Zehntel aller Ressourcen, aller Flächen, des Wassers, haben etwa ein Zehntel des CO2-Ausstoßes. Könnte ein toller Proteinträger sein, Eiweißträger. In Deutschland oder im Europa ist es halt nicht im Kulturkreis irgendwie vorgesehen. Sondern wir sind so erzogen, dass wir ih sagen und äh.
Hier haben ja schon Vegetarier einen schweren Stand. Wenn man dann noch als Ameisenfresser bezeichnet wird, dann könnte es schwierig werden.
Also wir machen da Versuche, auch mit Wissenschaftlern, wir machen Lunch Talks, wo man alle Vorteile von Insekten essen in den Vortrag zählen. Und wo wir dann Insekten anbieten, gut zubereitet und da gibt es der Gruppen. Die einen sagen, probiere ich mal, die haben da überhaupt kein Problem. Die andere Gruppe sagt schon, alle ungefähr so ein Drittel, ein Drittel, ein Drittel. Die andere Gruppe sagt, kann ich nicht ich, da könnt ihr mir erzählen was ihr wollt, aber ich kann das einfach nicht essen. Und die interessantesten sind die, die sagen, ich bin eigentlich rational überzeugt, dass das eine gute Option wäre. Und die haben dann die Heuschrecke, die Wüstengarnele, da geht es natürlich auch ums Labeling. Also die Heuschrecke haben die dann im Mund und schaffen es nicht, die abzubeißen. Also da ist dann so eine Schranke drin eine kulturelle und das ist eigentlich spannend. Und wenn man sich dem aber teilweise auch … das kann ja auch Spaß machen so eine Hilfesuche, wenn man sich dem so nähert, dann kann man vielleicht zu dem Schluss kommen, ja vielleicht ist es wirklich nichts hier für Deutschland oder Europa, aber vielleicht für die Aquakultur.
Also weil wir ja auch bei der Fischzucht das Überfischungsproblem. Wir essen eigentlich nur gerne Fische, die andere Fische, also carnivore Fische, die andere Fische fressen. Und deswegen müssen wir viel Fisch zufüttern, teilweise das fünffache von dem was wir dann gewinnen. Da gibt es jetzt Versuche, Fische den Lachs umzuprogrammieren auf Vegetariertum. Oder aber man nimmt halt dann Insekten. Die also wieder wie Shrimps und so biologisch ganz nahe zusammenpassen. Da gibt es auch tolle Forschungsprojekte übrigens. Und solche Diskussionen könnten auf verschlungenen Wegen teilweise, weil man da erst mal selbst ausprobiert und sagt, könnte ich ja selber essen, sagen, nein ist nichts für mich, aber die Fische vielleicht. Also so kann man weiterkommen, so kann man sich Dinge besser vorstellen, man muss sich damit beschäftigen und das ist glaube ich wichtig.
Jetzt haben wir im Prinzip schon so zwei Sachen so ein bisschen so vermischt. Auf der einen Seite so, welche Modelle kann die Wissenschaft anbieten der Gesellschaft, um sozusagen ein Umdenken auch einzuleiten, auch wenn ich ehrlich gesagt das Gefühl habe, dass das zwar wünschenswerte Effekte im Einzelnen sind, die letztlich auch andere politische Prozesse unterfüttern könnten, aber ja derzeit vor allem auch quick Action gefragt ist im großen Maßstab, also im Industriellen. Allein Transporte, was der Schiffsverkehr auf vielen Ebenen bewirkt ist ja, würde man da schnell zu Änderungen kommen, würde man sehr viel umfangreichere Änderungen herbeiführen als durch die Änderung des Lebenswandels von diversen Leuten. Nochmal kurz nachgefragt, denken Sie, dass die Wissenschaft, ist ein bisschen schwierig, das so zu beschreiben, aber sagen wir mal so die wissenschaftliche Sphäre, da jetzt sozusagen schon ist?
Dass sie der Gesellschaft mit breiter Brust entgegen springt und sagt, Leute hört mal auf mit euren Fakediskussionen, so geht es nicht weiter, bitte Änderung jetzt oder ist da auch noch was zu tun?
Also der Warnruf der Wissenschaft ist im wesentlichen groß genug, dass es eigentlich reichen sollte, um Dinge zu ändern.
Also aus dem Verständnis der Wissenschaft heraus?
Aus dem Verständnis der Wissenschaft heraus ja.
Und man wundert sich, warum hört uns keiner zu.
Das wäre mein Aber. Und ich habe mal einen Test gemacht, der mir wirklich die Augen geöffnet hat. Ich habe populärwissenschaftliche Bücher von Wissenschaftlern genommen und habe mal gesagt, was empfehlen die uns für die Zukunft? Also wenn die so ein bisschen ihre eigene Forschung umsetzen in Richtung, wie kann es mit der Zukunft weitergehen? Und da bin ich zu einem, ich nenne es mal mein Zukunfts-Fünfeck, gestoßen, ich konnte fünf Häufchen machen. Also bei den Wissenschaftlern gab es nur warnende Rufe, nach dem Motto „Business as usual“, da fahren wir den Karren an die Wand. Also das will eigentlich keiner. Das wäre so dieser erste Zukunftspfad, der von der Wissenschaft wirklich doch auch eigentlich eher abgelehnt wird. Ganz viel wird es sich häufeln in einem was ich reaktiven Zukunftspfad nenne. Wo es heißt, ja wir müssen halt eben, wir können jetzt da nicht die großen Revolutionen machen, wir müssen jetzt inkrementell weitergehen und müssen eben reagieren, wenn wir eine wachsende Weltbevölkerung ernähren müssen, dann muss eben die Produktivität steigen und solche Dinge.
Wenn wir Neubauten machen, wenn wir die Städte vergrößern, dann müssen wir eben da kräftig mitdenken, dass wir uns keine neuen Probleme schaffen oder so etwas, ich nenne das den reaktiven Weg. In der Medizin wird der noch ganz lange bleiben, weil wenn wir krank sind, dann nehmen wir irgendeine Medizin, die das hoffentlich wieder bessert, das ist eine Reaktion. Es gibt andere die sagen, wir müssen nein weniger ist mehr, der Suffizienzweg. Also bei Gesellschaftssystemen, weg von Kapitalismus, Eigenbeschränkung, mehr lokales, auch aus der Wissenschaft kommt so was, auch aus den Sozialwissenschaften natürlich ganz kräftig. Und wenn ich beim Thema Klima bleibe oder beim Essen, ja vegetarisch, vegan am besten vielleicht noch hier. Ansonsten bei der Energie weniger verbrauchen, Häuser besser dämmen, mehr einen dickeren Pulli anziehen, was auch immer. Nicht immer die Kurzurlaube machen etc.
Die nächste Ecke wäre, ich nenne es den bioadaptiven Weg oder den Konsistenzweg, der so in Richtung Cradle to Cradle, also Kreislaufwirtschaft geht. Wenn Sie Herrn Baumgart, den Sie auch schon interviewt haben, fragen, natürlich können wir weiter wachsen, wir müssen es nur im System halten das Ganze. Also ein auch sehr spannender Weg. Und es ist egal, ob das Essen von Übersee kommt, wenn es da nach Möglichkeit sogar bio ist und wenn die Energie halt eine erneuerbare ist und das Verpackungsmaterial essen wir vielleicht auf oder können es so kompostieren, dass da sogar was besseres rauskommt dabei. Ganz stark davon abhängig, dass wir eben wirklich beliebig viel Energie haben. Und dann könnten wir noch so eine Art super Hightech Weg denken, wo wir sagen, machen wir es doch ganz anders, wieso da immer essen und ernten, wir mixen das zusammen, so ähnlich wie Astronautennahrung, ich überspitze jetzt so ein bisschen, auch viele ethische Fragen, wie weit gehen wir bei Mensch-Maschine-Beziehungen? Bei uns selbst hier, was ist die Ethik, wenn wir an uns selbst eben rumschrauben.
Oder da werden dann auch Sachen wie … ja wir verklappen jetzt also nicht irgendwie CO2, sondern wir machen halt völlig neue Sachen draus, wir machen künstliche Photosynthese und derartige Dinge. Das wären zumal idealtypische Zukunftspfade, mit denen man glaube ich ganz gut arbeiten kann aus meiner Sicht. Um auch mal zu zeigen, die Wissenschaft ist sich da nicht einig. Es sind auch Leute, die in der Gesellschaft stehen und jeder ringt auch nach der richtigen Methode und es gibt auch widerstreitende wissenschaftliche Ansichten dazu und die gehören auf den Tisch.
Also man hat schon ein einheitliches Ziel, aber man hat halt sehr unterschiedliche Vorschläge, wie man da hinkommt?
Sicherlich wird es nicht so in einen dieser Pfade münden, sondern es wird Kompromisse geben oder Mischungen, je nach Kulturkreis, je nach Problematik hier. Da ist das eine mal mehr reaktiv, Medizin hatte ich da genannt, das andere Mal mehr in Richtung Suffizienz oder vielleicht kommen wir zum Cradle to Cradle Pfad erst mal über einen reaktiven oder über einen Hightech Pfad, damit wir da mal irgendwie landen. So ein Turnschuh, den wir bislang kompostieren können – ich überspitze es jetzt ein bisschen – der macht die Welt auch noch nicht alleine besser. Also es ist halt noch ein langer Weg und so lange können wir auch wieder nicht warten, bis wir alle Technologien haben und das immer wieder auseinanderzunehmen und zusammenzusetzen. Also vielleicht müssen wir in fünf Richtungen da oder in vier Richtungen weiterdenken. Und das zuzulassen und auch zu sehen, wir sollten vielleicht sogar vermeiden, wieder in so einen festen fixen Pfad reinzugeraten, um dann wieder nicht mehr rauszukommen, so wie es halt heute auch ist. Wenn Sie ein Kohlekraftwerk bauen, dann muss sich das rentieren.
Wenn Sie die Autos haben und die Firmen sich darauf spezialisiert haben, dann ist natürlich erst mal schon nachvollziehbar, dass die nicht sagen von heute auf morgen, wir bauen das ganz um. Vielleicht müssen wir da leichter bleiben in manchen Bereichen. Und die Turnover-Rate für Technologien wird wahrscheinlich sehr viel rascher sein, als wir das bislang hatten. Und das ist nicht nur was bedrohliches, das kann ja auch was positives sein.
Weil man auch die Chance hat, das wieder loszuwerden, was sich vielleicht nicht ganz so bewehrt hat.
Genau.
Stellt sich mir die Frage, sehen Sie denn Wissenschaft und konkret sagen wir mal diese Perspektive auch, die jetzt hier zu den ganzen Überlegungen des Anthropozäns dazugehört, ausreichend in der Schulbildung verankert? Ist das nicht eigentlich die stärkste Kraft sozusagen die nächste Generation zu nehmen. Ich meine, na gut wir haben vielleicht noch so ein bisschen zu leben, aber umso länger man dabei ist, umso mehr tendiert man dazu, das ja sozusagen nur noch als so ein Randproblem zu sehen, aber in dem Moment, wo man noch das ganze Leben vor sich hat, setzt das ja ganz andere Energien frei. Also ich kann mich selber noch dran erinnern, wie in den 80er Jahren ja im Prinzip diese neue Umweltbewegung in Deutschland, die dann auch die Grünen hervorgebracht hat und so weiter, sich eigentlich bei den jungen Leuten extrem manifestiert hat.
So dass so dieser Grundwille des Wandels, dieses Unverständnis für Atomenergie etc. dann doch langfristig auch wirklich die Basis geschaffen hat und dann auch bestimmte grundlegende politische Wechsel einzuleiten, selbst wenn sie erst 10-20 Jahre später stattgefunden haben. Ist aber auch eine Frage der Bildung.
Also wir dürfen nicht vergessen, dass wirkliche schon viel passier ist auch, und dass es auch länger dauert, bis sich dann neue Dinge dann so manifestieren, dass sie wirklich auch echt sichtbar werden. Es ist aber, ich gebe Ihnen vorkommen recht, auch eine Frage der Schulbildung. Vielleicht kann ich kurz einfließen lassen, als ich hierher gefahren bin zu diesem Interview, war plötzlich die Straßenbahn voll mit einer wilden Schulklasse, so 8-Jährige, wo ich erst gedacht habe, du liebe Zeit, ich wollte mich doch gerade ein bisschen konzentrieren und dann habe ich die lachenden Gesichter angesehen und auch die engagierten Lehrer, die da dabei war und was da für ein Leben drin war und da dachte ich, jede Anstrengung ist richtig und recht, die Erde so zu hinterlassen, dass diese Generation dieselben Chancen hat, die wir hatten und nicht nur reagieren muss, sondern auch noch frei agieren kann. Das mal so vielleicht ein bisschen pathetisch, aber ich habe es wirklich so gefühlt, und es gibt mir auch Kraft, so was immer wieder mal zu sehen.
Ich sehe, gut Schulen kann ich gerne gleich noch drauf kommen, sehr gute Schulen auch zum Teil, aber ich sehe ein Grundproblem eigentlich unserer ganzen Gesellschaft, dass wir so vieles so sektoral strukturiert haben. Das sind die Universitäten, da gibt es dann mal Exzellenzinitiativen, wo man schon enger interdisziplinär zusammenarbeitet. Schauen Sie sich eine Stadtverwaltung an oder auch die Ministerien, jeder kümmert sich um seine Probleme und ist froh, wenn er da irgendwie vorankommt und reagieren kann. Aber es ist oft so kleinteilig, dass ich wirklich oft die Hände überm Kopf zusammenschlage. Und an Schulen gibt es halt nach wie vor die Fächer, die will ich jetzt gar nicht wirklich abschaffen hier, aber es ist auch nicht so leicht, hier themenübergreifenden Unterricht zu machen. Das gibt es, das geht. Wir arbeiten da auch dran, Lehrer zu motivieren, indem wir ihnen Lehrerhandreichungen, Dinge produzieren, damit sie sich auch trauen, Projektunterricht zu machen.
Übergreifenden Unterricht zu machen. Es ist nicht ganz einfach, aber es funktioniert. Es gibt einige sehr vorbildliche Schulen. Ich war vor kurzem mal wieder an der evangelischen Schule hier in Berlin, die ein Global Goals Curriculum gemacht hat, wo man also wirklich nur sich freuen konnte, wie da Schüler auch engagiert sind, fachübergreifend Dinge anzupacken und die auch durchzudenken. Es gibt die Design-Thinking Ansätze, sich in Stakeholder reinzudenken, in andere Empathie quasi auch zu üben oder wirklich Rollenspiele zu machen. Das sind glaube ich ganz ganz wichtige Bildungsansätze, die wir auch brauchen, weil wir ja auch miteinander in einer geeigneten Weise auskommen müssen. Also die Schulen sind eine Schlüsselrolle und ich begrüße aber jede Anstrengung, die schulische Ausbildung noch besser zu machen, und vor allem mehr Projektunterricht und fachübergreifenden Unterricht reinzubringen.
Ich brauche kein neues Schulfach Nachhaltigkeit oder gar Anthropozän oder so etwas hier, ganz und gar nicht, aber ich glaube es wäre wichtig hier, auch ähnlich wie in der Wissenschaft, auch hier mehr Querschnitte zu schaffen.
Wie wäre es, wenn jeder junge Wissenschaftler oder vielleicht auch die älteren auch mal 2-4 Stunden in einer Schule quasi als Pflichtprogramm abzuleisten hätten, um ihr Diplom einzusammeln?
Fände ich gut, und also ich habe das sehr früh schon auch selbst gemacht und ich freue mich jedes mal, wenn ich bei einer Schüleruni auftreten kann oder wenn wir irgendein Projekt haben. Ich habe auch schon Promotionen ausgegeben, wo sehr tolle Sachen rausgekommen sind. Umweltmonitoring mit Schulen, was dann im Wesentlichen ganz eigenständig durch die Schüler dann durchgeführt wird mit Materialien, die sie sich …
Gibt es da eher mehr Nachfrage oder mehr Angebot? Also wer muss sich da mehr bewegen, die Schulen oder die …
Es sind einzelne Lehrer, die das Angebot sehr gerne aufnehmen. Aber sie haben schon Schwierigkeiten, das zum Teil so zu integrieren. Das kennen wir ja aus der Wissenschaft und allen Lebensbereichen, es kann auch passieren, das die anderen Kollegen mal ein bisschen kritisch gucken, was machen die denn da so gerade, muss ich das dann vielleicht auch noch machen? Also dieser kleine Stimulus was vorzumachen über Beispiele zu zeigen, dass es gut läuft, ich glaube dass da auch neues Sinn machen kann, das ist glaube ich eine ganz wichtige Sache. Es muss auch das vorsichtige Gestalten des Anthropozäns, wenn ich es mal so nennen darf, das muss auch Spaß machen und das muss auch unseren Jungen Spaß machen und deswegen finden wir manchmal auch über Umwege zu solchen Themen. Und das finde ich richtig.
Mir fällt an dieser Stelle auch noch das Gespräch ein, was ich hier mit Uwe Schneidewind gehabt habe, über transformative Wissenschaft, der im Prinzip eine ähnliche These auch verfolgt an der Stelle. Allerdings das gar nicht mal nur jetzt über die Bildung organisiert sehen möchte, sondern eben auch konkret mit den Kommunen zum Beispiel zusammenzuarbeiten. Also auch an der Stelle so eine transdisziplinäre Verflechtung der wissenschaftlichen Arbeit postuliert. Sehr interessantes Gespräch, Forschergeist Ausgabe Nummer 25. Da nicken Sie schon. Jetzt würde ich zum Schluss nochmal etwas aufgreifen, was Sie auch mehrfach gesagt haben, was jetzt auch hier überall durchdringt, nämlich die Frage der Kommunikation, der Vermittlung dieser Thesen und dieser Aufgaben. Sie sind da ja auch ganz umtriebig.
Nicht nur dass es ein Blog gibt von Ihnen bei Scilogs, der Anthropozäniker, wo Sie vieles sicherlich von dem thematisieren, was wir jetzt hier auch schon angesprochen haben. Aber Sie erwähnten auch eine Ausstellung in München. Was war das für eine Ausstellung, wo fand die statt, was hatte die für einen Ansatz und Umfang?
Die Ausstellung hieß „Willkommen im Anthropozän“, also durchaus ein positiver Aufschlag. Und dann im Nebentitel „Unsere Verantwortung für die Zukunft der Erde“. Die lief von Dezember 2014 bis jetzt Ende September 2016. Also ist gut.
Ist relativ lang auch?
Relativ lang ja. Ist sehr gut besucht worden am Deutschen Museum, ich war damals ein Fellow an einem interdisziplinären Zentrum, was ich mir ganz bewusst ausgesucht habe, Rachel Carson Centre for Environment in Society, der Titel sagt schon, dass es da interdisziplinär zugeht und da habe ich das Rahmenkonzept entwickelt und die Ausstellung angestoßen und dann natürlich mit ganz vielen anderen zusammen mich dann auch noch bei der Umsetzung etwas mit eingebracht. Und zuvor hatten wir in Berlin schon angestoßen, das Anthropozän-Projekt am Haus der Kulturen der Welt, was auf einer bisschen anderen Ebene war, eher also es gab sehr viele Diskussionen etc. Diese fachliche Diskussionen, da war auch die Anthropozän-Working-Group mal da und die waren auch München dann mal. Aber da ging es jetzt wirklich mehr um die Breitenwirkung. Und da wollten wir schon auch einerseits sagen, ja wie sieht der heutige Zustand der Erde aus, was ist die Rolle der Technik?
Also Teil des Problems, aber wohl auch Teil der Lösung, auch die Rolle der Wissenschaften. Wie kann man neue Denkansätze machen? Wir hatten als Kunstobjekt die Uhr des langen Jetzt, die also nur so alle tausend Jahre mal einmal tickt und so ein bisschen, um da mal in anderen Skalen zu denken. Wir hatten dann eben Lösungsansätze auch etwa beim Thema Essen. Das geht so in Richtung dieser Szenarien, die ich vorhin so allgemein geschildert habe. Also da ging es auch drum, es ging ein bisschen um Insekten essen, es ging um Urban Gardening, als Suffizienzmodell. Es ging natürlich um die technischen Verfahren, wir haben Haber-Bosch-Verfahren und was es da so alles gibt, auch mit dargestellt.
Was ist das?
Das ist wie wir eben unseren Stickstoff, den wir für alles und jedes brauchen, gewinnen, einfach aus der Luft. Pflanzen können das ja gar nicht so wirklich gut, das können nur wenige. Und Lupinen etc. und wir machen das eben großtechnisch und kommen da zu unserem Stickstoffdünger. Bei Phosphor ist es schwieriger, da gibt es sehr sehr endliche Ressourcen, weswegen ja schon ganze politische Krisen waren und etwa Marokko die Westsahara annektiert hat, weil dort die Hauptressourcen der ganzen Welt für Phosphate sind. Um da nochmal so diese geopolitischen Aspekte einfließen zu lassen, die wir da auch in geeignetem Umfang dargestellt haben. Es sollte also auch durchaus eine Ausstellung sein, die ein bisschen Mut macht. Dann auch die Leistungen, die wir so haben, natürlich dargestellt worden und man durfte dann auch in Richtung Zukunftsvision selbst noch sich Dinge wünschen, in Form von Blumen, wo man die Wünsche an die Zukunft uraufgeschrieben hat.
Oder Vorstellungen, die wir dann immer wieder abgeerntet haben, wenn das Blumenfeld voll war und das dann auch dokumentiert haben. Und da haben wir übrigens auch, weil ja eigentlich das Deutsche Museum mit seinen Objekten ja ein Museum ist, was den Weg in Richtung Anthropozän aufzeigt und dann haben wir die Dauerausstellung auch noch kontextualisiert. Dieselmotor und viele viele Dampfmaschinen und viele andere Dinge mit großmaßstäblichen Comics und haben das dann auch als Buch noch herausgegeben.
Wollte ich gleich nochmal zurückkommen. Mir fällt jetzt nur gerade ein, also Ausstellung finde ich immer eine tolle Sache. Das sieht gut aus, kann man mal hingehen, macht man sich einen schönen Nachmittag und dann ist man aber auch meistens schon wieder raus und wie viel davon hängenbleibt ist sicherlich auch schwer zu bewerten. Vielleicht auch ein bisschen ein Teil meiner Zurückhaltung ist, die ich hier gerade äußere. Ich frage mich, ist das, also nicht dass man das nicht machen sollte, aber ist das so die wichtigste Methode? Ist hier vielleicht auch schon drüber nachgedacht worden, auch so eine Ausstellung, in die ja eine ganze Menge vorbereitende Arbeit fließt, das bedeutet ja, man setzt sich mal hin, man plant, man macht sich über Objekte Gedanken, über die Texte, über die komplette Pädagogik, die ja im Prinzip beim Durchlaufen einer solchen Ausstellung abläuft, ist denn nicht, wenn diese Arbeit schon gemacht ist, wäre das nicht auch eine sehr gute Basis, um zum Beispiel daraus auch Arbeitsmaterialien für die Schule zu schaffen?Ist das vielleicht getan worden?
Ja. Gebe ich Ihnen vollkommen recht. Also nachher nochmal kurz zur Ausstellung, aber eine Ausstellung braucht natürlich ein Drumherum. Und es gab ganz viele Workshops, es gab Schulmaterialien, die wir erstellt haben. Es gab ganz viele Schulklassen, die ihren Unterricht dort auch gemacht haben. Also das gehört natürlich auf alle Fälle auch dazu. Und wir haben auch viele Umfragen gemacht, ob denn da was hängen bleibt und wie die Leute das sehen. Und das waren wirklich nicht nur Vorinteressierte drin, und es war auch die Ausstellung so konzipiert, dass man schon beim Reingehen Kunstobjekte gesehen hat, offensichtlich künstlerische Dinge oder auch ein gehäkeltes Korallenriff zum Beispiel. Aber man sah einen Roboter einen alten. Man sah aus so einem Naturkundemuseum Tiere und die Leute sind erst mal dahin gelaufen, was sie am meisten interessiert hat und haben sich von da aus die Ausstellung erarbeitet.
Und das ist glaube ich wichtig, auch für Ausstellungen, aber auch für andere Formate, dass wir nicht nur solche linearen Formate haben. Man versteht Vitrine 3 nur, wenn man Vitrine 1 und 2 zuvor gesehen hat. Dann kann man gleich ein Buch lesen oder ein Film, wo es so linear abläuft, sich anschauen. Sondern man muss da partizipativ, ich will das Wort nicht überbeanspruchen, aber man muss sch darauf einlassen, man muss es sich zum Teil selbst erarbeiten. Und das ist glaube ich wichtig bei den komplexen Themen, dass man sich so eine Art Kopfkino quasi macht und viele Eindrücke hat und es sich dann selbst auch nochmal sehr reflektiv zusammenbauen muss. Und eigentlich auch nicht so unbedingt eine fertige Lösung zusammen bekommt. Und da eignen sich Ausstellungen, die eben visualisieren können, die verschiedene Skalen bearbeiten können, die den historischen Aspekt und den Zukunftsaspekt gleichzeitig mit einbauen können, eignen sich schon ganz gut, aber eben auch andere Formate. Und deswegen arbeiten wir auch mit grafischen Formaten und Comics.
Ich bin jetzt einer gewesen, der Comics in der Kindheit gelesen hat und dann lange nicht mehr. Aber ich habe es jetzt wiederentdeckt, was man da so alles damit machen kann. Sie können emotionale Geschichten erzählen. Sie können Personen darstellen. Sie können die miteinander reden lassen. Sie könne sogar Geräusche simulieren. Manchmal meint man, man kann was riechen was da drin ist. Und Sie können Fakten, Infografiken in einer speziellen Darstellung mit Narrativen verbinden und auch da, wir machen da auch Untersuchungen dazu, wir machen auch Lehrerhandreichungen für diese Comics, damit man so was in den Unterricht bringen kann. Wir haben gerade ein Forschungsprojekt, wo wir mit Eyetracker-Methoden schauen, worauf schaut man als erstes und wie erarbeitet man sich dann diesen Gesamtkontext weiter, was ist interessant, was wird schnell durchgeblättert. Also da steckt richtig Forschung auch dahinter. Und es kommt auch aus der Forschung, auch so der interdisziplinären Forschung, wo wir diese Bücher dann generieren.
Und das ist jetzt nicht allein das Mittel der Wahl, aber es kann den Kanon, wie wir kommunizieren, ergänzen. Wenn ich das vielleicht jetzt von ganz breit sagen darf, wir müssen wegkommen davon, dass wir nur Wissenstransfer machen. Das weiß die hehre Wissenschaft. Und sehr brav wird das jetzt rübertransferiert. Sondern wir brauchen echte eigene Räume. Die können auch virtuell sein, die können auch nur im Kopf sein, wo eine echte Kommunikation stattfindet. Da gibt es so ein Modell, da ist also Raum 1 die Wissensgenerierung, Raum 2 ist also wir wollen das Publikum oder der Steuerzahler, der das auch erst ermöglicht, und da darf es nicht nur so einen Transfer geben, sondern da muss es einen Raum 3 geben, in dem sich beide austauschen können und auch gegenseitig befruchten können. Und alle Formate, die dazu beitragen, sind die richtigen und die wichtigen und persönliche Begegnungen sind da glaube ich auch sehr wichtig.
Gerade in unserer heutigen Zeit, wo wir in Echoräumen, Resonanzräumen, Echokammern oft gar nicht rauskommen, also Begegnungen sind glaube ich für die Wissenschaftskommunikation und auch für die Wissenschaft in Zukunft noch wichtiger, als die das schon waren.
Oder Podcasts.
Das gibt es auch die drei Räume, an der Stelle auch eine Einladung an alle Hörerinnen und Hörer auch nochmal in den Kommentaren vorbeizuschauen, wo sich nicht selten dann noch interessante Nachfragen und Diskussionen ergeben zu dem Podcast. Das heißt ich höre jetzt raus, dass die Ausstellung dann auch noch ein digitales Nachleben hat oder noch nicht?
Und Podcasts ja.
In einem gewissen Umfang dort im Deutschen Museum. Deutsches Museum ist gerade am großen Umbau eines Masterplans, so dass ein Teil davon digital vorhanden ist. Aber jetzt in diesem Fall nicht alles. Aber es gibt ja ein anderes großen Projekt, an dem ich mit beteiligt war als Gründungsdirektor das Haus der Zukunft, was jetzt als Futurium unbenannt worden ist. Und genau das soll so eine Stätte sein, wo man sich auch begegnet, wo man in einem Reallabor Dinge ausprobieren kann, die man vielleicht sonst nicht ausprobieren würde. Wo so ein Labor auch wandert zu den sonstigen Wissenschaften hin, wo es auch wieder Ausstellungen geben wird, wo diese Fragen, gibt es nur die eine Zukunft oder können wir uns die vielfältig vorstellen, auch behandelt werden sollen. Also das wollte ich nur mal so ganz kurz erwähnen, dass es natürlich viele Häuser gibt und auch dieses Thema Anthropozän auch an anderen Häusern durchaus fruchtbar nun aufgegriffen wird.
Ja. Haus der Zukunft, Futurium ist ein …?
Das ist eine Einrichtung.
Also es ist ein Ort?
Es wird ein Ort. Das Richtfest war schon. Das wird gehe ich mal davon aus nächstes Jahr eröffnet werden.
Wo wird das dann sein?
Direkt beim Hauptbahnhof in Berlin.
Bleiben wir noch ein bisschen bei der Kommunikation. Sie haben ja auch noch Bücher herausgebracht der besonderen Art möchte ich mal sagen. Hier liegt gerade eins vor mir. Sie haben vorhin schon gesagt, Comic. Das hat ja bei vielen immer eine merkwürdige Konnotation, aber vielleicht können Sie mal kurz sagen, wie es zu diesem Projekt kam. Das was ich in der Hand halte ist das dritte glaube ich schon in der Reihe.
Das ist von den Büchern das dritte in so einer Art Reihe ja. Also das ist nun ein Buch, was wir an einem Exzellenzcluster hier in Berlin namens Bild-Wissen-Gestaltung nun hervorgebracht haben an der Humboldt-Universität, aber eben mit allen Universitäten Berlins eigentlich gemeinsam. Und dort arbeiten Kulturwissenschaftler, Designer, Architekten und Naturwissenschaftler eben zusammen. Und ich bin hier der sogenannten PI, der Principal Investigator eines Unterprojektes. Nennt sich die Anthropozänküche, das Labor der Verknüpfung von Haus und Welt. Soll also heißen einfach gesagt, wir haben in der Küche nicht nur den Kochlöffel in der Hand, sondern auch den Steuerhebel der Globalisierung und wir haben das Thema eben deswegen herausgepickt, weil es ein Thema ist, was jeden angeht und wo man auch einen emotionalen Bezug dazu hat.
Und gerade weil das so ist, haben wir gedacht, das sollten wir jetzt nicht nur von der wissenschaftlichen Ebene her. Wir haben da natürlich Symposien und alles mögliche veranstaltet, um da auch die Spezialisten, etwa auch zu Insektenernährung mit einzuladen. Aber wir haben gesagt, nein wir wollen auch das sonstige Wissen, was vorhanden ist, neben dem wissenschaftlichen Wissen in geeigneter Weise mit einbinden, Erfahrungswissen und wollen in den Dialog treten mit Leuten und deswegen haben wir uns aus 10 Ländern, in 5 Kontinenten, 10 Protagonisten oder Protagonistengruppen gesucht, mit denen wir einfach uns unterhalten haben. Einfache Fragen gestellt haben, was esst ihr, wo kauft ihr das ein, wisst ihr wo es herkommt, wie ist das Essen in euer Alltagsleben integriert und habet ihr ein besonderes Rezept, was ihr besonders gerne kocht. Und aus diesen Antworten sind dann die eigentlichen Dialogen entstanden und auch der Recherchebedarf.
Also es ist eine echt transdisziplinäre Forschung, weil wir zwar mit einem bestimmten Framing reingegangen sind, aber wirklich erst nach diesen Gesprächen entschieden haben, und auch vieles verworfen haben, was da wirklich reinkommt. Es geht um Gesundheitsaspekte.
Also das klingt ja erst mal nach Kochbuch?
Es finden in Berlin in einer großen Buchhandlung finden Sie das bei den Kochbüchern aufgestellt, weil wirklich 10 Rezepte drin sind. Anderswo finden Sie es in der Umweltabteilung, es war auch schonmal in Lifestyle. Also es geht uns um die Ressourcen.
In welcher Abteilung wäre es Ihnen denn am liebsten eigentlich?
Am liebsten in allen. Von Comic, in Kochbuch, weil das sich viele raustun.
Politik und Gesellschaft?
Politik und Gesellschaft und natürlich bei Umwelt. Da wäre es mir am liebsten. Das ist ein gewisses Thema bei diesen systemischen Problemen, bei diesen systemischen Themen, dass sie es einfach nicht mehr so leicht verorten können, ja wo gehört es denn eigentlich hin?
Jetzt sind wir im Prinzip bei diesen neuen Narrativen, die Sie vorhin ja schon eingeklagt haben. Der in diesem Fall konkret ist, okay wir denken einfach mal über Essen nach und wie unterschiedlich ist Ernährungsform und natürlich auch Nahrungsmittelgewinnung aufgestellt. Und daraus leiten Sie quasi Thesen über das Anthropozän ab?
Also das Buch ist, so könnte man vielleicht sagen, eine auch nur exemplarische bei nur 10 Gruppen, exemplarische Kartierung der vorhandenen Ernährungsstile auf dieser Welt, in ihrer Einbettung in Globalisierung, Ressourcensituation, politischer und auch kulturell-gesellschaftlicher Kontext bis hin zu medizinischen Aspekten und so weiter.
Nennen Sie mal ein Beispiel eines dieser 10 Geschichten.
Also zum Beispiel die Geschichte aus, nehmen wir mal Marokko, da kann man eine tolle Tagine nachkochen, da geht es um die Geschichte, dass unsere Protagonisten eben eigentlich im hohen Atlas früher gearbeitet haben, wo man dann wegen Schutzsituationen nicht mehr rein konnte und das alles verlassen wurden und aber hier jetzt doch versucht wird, in Projekten hier ein Auskommen auch zu finden, indem man auch neue Züchtungen macht von etwa Mandeln etc., die dann da oben gut wachsen können. Und verhindert, dass alle etwa in der Phosphatindustrie nun landen. Denn die Phosphatindustrie hat hier weltpolitische Bedeutung. Marokko hat die Hauptweltressourcen allen Phosphats. Es braucht die ganze Welt quasi. Es gibt noch ein paar andere Fundstellen, aber das allermeiste kommt aus Marokko. Und es sind so Geschichten dabei, wie das vielleicht dieses Phosphat, was bei uns im Gehirn, in der DNA, in den Muskeln überall ist, dass dieses Phosphat möglicherweise aus Marokko stammt.
Und da in der Kreidezeit, als die Dinosaurier noch rumgelaufen sind, abgelagert wurde. Also solche Geschichten lassen wir da so anklingen. In Deutschland ist es schon die Massenproduktion von Fleisch, was wir da thematisieren. Und auch die Frage, gibt es denn neue Möglichkeiten und die Protagonistin, eine Studierende aus der FU aus der Zoologie, die mit Insekten arbeitet, hat eben festgestellt, dass der lokale Imker, die FU leistet sich einen Imker, dass der Imker die Bienendrohnen immer wegschmeißt, das machen alle Imker so, denn die müsste man nur durchfüttern, das sind quasi die …
… die Männchen.
Ja die Männchen. Also es sind die Brüterhündchen der Bienen und die haben dann experimentiert, ob man das nicht essen kann. Und da gibt es dann das Rezept des Drohnenbienenstichs, den wir dann auch bei Buchvorstellungen immer wieder mal nachmachen und da kann man mal auf spielerische Weise dann eben sagen, ja es gibt da vielleicht Alternativen, auch wenn das vielleicht nur ein kleines Teil eines Portfolios sein könnte, aber dann geht es eben hier auch um die Frage, könnten Insekten eine Alternative sein. Und am Schluss des Buchs gibt es dann eine Art wissenschaftliche Analyse, wie es weitergehen könnte, mit meinen vier Zukunftspfaden, die da auf so einer Doppelseite sind und dann zum nachdenken anregen sollen. Aber wir haben die Künstler, die Künstler stammen ja aus den jeweiligen Ländern, es ist also quietschbunt eigentlich geworden dieses Buch. Wir haben die Künstler gebeten, mal Postkarten aus dem Jahr 2050 zu schicken, wie sie sich dann die Welt vorstellen, nachdem die Künstler alle bei einem wissenschaftlichen Kongress dabei waren.
Zu diesem Thema, die wir also extra eingeladen hatten. Wo Ernährungsspezialisten da waren und das ist auch ganz spannend geworden. Also wir lassen auch so eine nicht wissenschaftliche oder nach einer gewissen wissenschaftlichen Auseinandersetzung generierte Zukunftsvision da mal zu, einfach um das Nachdenken anzuregen.
Ja also es ist sicherlich nochmal wert, das zu betonen. Ich bin ganz beeindruckt muss ich sagen von dieser Zusammenstellung. Also nichts nur, dass hier sozusagen diese Narrative über so eine nachvollziehbare Geschichte hergeleitet werden, eben über Nahrung, Ernährung bzw. Herstellung dieser Nahrungsmittel, sondern dadurch, dass das eben auch im Prinzip Geschichte aus bestimmten Regionen dieses Planeten sind, wird dadurch dass man auf lokale Künstler quasi zurückgreift, die das halt in Bildsprache umsetzen, .. ich habe jetzt nicht alles gelesen, aber alleine vom Anschauen, man sieht halt sofort was europäisch ist. Man sieht sofort etwas, was aus Kulturen kommt, die wir nicht täglich erleben und spricht damit natürlich auch nochmal eine ganz andere Sprache. Macht einem vielleicht auch mal klar, dass sozusagen auch nicht unbedingt immer alles so eine eurozentristische Sicht verdient.
Das war uns ganz wichtig ja.
Genau, aber hat natürlich auch seinen wissenschaftlichen Teil mit Quellenliste, mit einem Glossar, um einfach auch die Begriffe verständlich zu machen.
Und es wird jetzt auch noch …
Wie praktisch, dass diese Sendung noch vor Weihnachten erscheint.
Nein um Gottes Willen. Nein wir haben es auch für Schulen gedacht. Es werden gerade noch Lehrerhandreichungen dazu gemacht. Und was glaube ich, Sie haben es sehr gut erkannt, wir sind auch in dieser Anthropozängruppe relativ viele Männer, es sind auch Frauen dabei, aber Dominanz von Männern, es ist westlich und man muss aufpassen, dass die Wissenschaft nicht aus einer bestimmten Sicht nun sagt, das ist das richtige für die Welt. Und deswegen war es uns wichtig hier, gerade fürs Anthropozän, wo ich der Meinung bin, wir brauchen so was wie einen Weltbürgergedanken, der muss aber die ganze Differenziertheit, die wir auf dieser Welt haben, abdecken können. Alle kulturellen Unterschiede so mit integrieren. Und da dachten wir, das ist ein Versuch wert, das eben in so einem Buch mal zu probieren. Wo wir also wirklich auf fünf Kontinenten sind und ganz unterschiedliche Ansätze haben, die wir in den Geschichten, aber dann eben auch in den Bildern, dann zum Ausdruck bringen. Das ist glaube ich wichtig, dass man das sieht, dass es eine Weltaufgabe ist.
Ja globaler kann die Herausforderung eigentlich kaum noch werden, als sie hier mit dem Begriff eigentlich zusammengefasst wird. Ja Herr Leinfelder ich weiß nicht, gibt es noch irgendeinen wichtigen Gedanken, den wir hier noch nicht aufgegriffen haben, den wir noch hinten anstellen sollten?
Ich glaube, wir haben jetzt über sehr vieles gesprochen, vielleicht bin ich auch bisschen weit immer weggekommen von Ihren direkten Fragen, Sie sehen, dass mich das selbst umtreibt natürlich auch. Und ich glaube, der Begriff ist in der Welt, ob er jetzt nun von der geologischen Community formal eingerichtet wird oder nicht, ich persönlich glaube ja, aber ich glaube der Mehrwert ist wirklich, dass wir nunmal so einen Begriff gefunden haben dafür, dass wir in den Wissenschaften, aber auch darüber hinaus, einfach noch stärker auf Kooperation und gegenseitiges Verständnis, gegenseitiges Zuhören setzen müssen. Und auch keine Überheblichkeiten aus der Wissenschaft glaube hilfreich sind, um nun ein zukunftsfähiges Anthropozän nun wirklich zu gestalten. Denn da kommt es auf alle an.
Das Anthropozän ist ein wissenschaftliches Konzept mit einer übergeordneten Verantwortungsebene. Wie wir dahin kommen ist eine große Weltaufgabe der Gesellschaft, der Politik, aber auch jedes einzelnen.
Ja Herr Leinfelder, dann sage ich vielen Dank für den Beitrag hier. Und natürlich auch wieder vielen Dank fürs Zuhören hier bei Forschergeist, bald geht es wieder weiter mit anderen Themen rund um die Wissenschaft. Und ich sage, tschüss und bis bald.